this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you so much Harold for the
introduction
thank you all for being
fine to listen to some of the results of
my
dissertation and research that I have
been doing four years
uh today I'm gonna talk about agronomic
production environments
impact info help and crop productivity
and analyzing some of the implications
of that interactions per system
sustainability
really
increasing global population and
increase of people living in cities is a
major concern for future sustainability
as we can see here in this map the
population in the globe is highly
unevenly distributed it is expected by
2050 that 7 out of 10 people are gonna
live in cities this is a huge concern
for many reasons one is that people is
getting farther apart from nature
but also food production is getting
farther apart from food consumers as we
can see some parts of Asia are not able
to produce the food they need to sustain
their populations
from a carbon and nutrient balance
perspective what is happening we can see
here in this map the example of soybean
production and consumption globally
basically the Americas we are producing
grains and we are sending those grains
to China and Asia where the grains are
used to produce mostly animal protein
for people
and with the grain we are sending carbon
nutrients and minerals
and the soils are the source of those
nutrients but they are also the source
of water energy and huge diversity of
microorganisms that facilitate many
ecosystem services not only the
production of food but also mitigating
on climate change
helping us to uh yeah to put to many
many ecosystem services
and with that so how actually what is
the definition of Soho is the capability
of the soils to provide those ecosystem
services
there are many discussions around what
terminology should we use to refer to
the capability of the soul to function
and I'm not going to talk about that
today but I do want to take some minutes
to talk about what I think there are
requirements that we should have when we
are trying to access soil health
so basically we say so health is the
capability of the source to function but
these functions or ecosystem services
are very hard to address directly so
what we do is we measure indicators in
the soil that should be therefore
connected so they be hierarchical
connected to the functions also what we
measure should be comprehensive because
we know that the functionality of the
soil will not rely only in one property
but will rely on an interaction between
physical biological and chemical
properties acting together
so with that Cornell comprehensive
assessment of soil Health that is the
framework that I use for most of my PhD
has been developing over the years
and selecting a set of indicators that
have these two characteristics but
additionally they are also easy to
measure meaning that we can provide
these measuring these indicators and
provide that as a service for Farmers
giving them a meaning and helping them
to make decisions in the forms
so the indicators I'm going to be
talking today from the physical
perspective include water aggregate
stability that is associated to the
resistance of the Aggregates to keep
this their shape and therefore related
processes in the soil like infiltration
and aeration we're also going to be
talking about available water capacity
that is how much water the soil can
retains and then penetration resistance
or hardness in the soil in surface on
the subsurface that is associated with a
compaction how easy can the roots grow
in the soil and access to the water and
the nutrients
from the biological perspective the
indicators we're going to be talking
about are soil organic matter the most
broadly measured soil Health indicator
that is related to many physical and
biological processes we're also going to
be talking about active carbon or foxy
that is the easy accessibility carbon
for the microorganisms and they say
protein Associated to the nitrogen
availability for microbial community and
respiration that is mostly related to
the microbial Community abundance and
activity
and we also have a set of Chemical
indicators and these indicators aim to
reflect the availability of nutrients
per plant and in some cases also
toxicities or problems that we might
have with potential pollution risks
today I'm gonna be focusing mostly in
physical and biological indicators
because we have been talking a little
bit less about these indicators but also
because Chemical indicators most of the
times we cut we can correct in short
term by adding fertilizers who are
physical and biological indicators in
order to modify those we need to plan
ahead and we'll take a little bit more
time
but basically then what we are doing is
with the lack one indicator let's set
aggregate instability because we know
that it's related for example with water
incorporation and we expect that if we
have higher water infiltration therefore
we're going to have better crop growth
but we are all here agronomies are
working in biology know that this is not
that good
and there are many factors associated
with management and clima that will
affect growth that are Beyond uh
infiltration
and at the same time these factors are
also affecting aggregate stability and I
am sure that I can start asking each one
of you what else should I add this
diagram to make it complete and we're
going to spend here all day and keep
adding complexities
and actually full health is very complex
and its relationship with functions is
even more complex
and that will lead me to my final
requirement for a soil Health assessment
that is the need of having contact a
specific assessments
basically
soil health is defined by a very complex
interaction between inherent properties
that are defined by the main sole
forming factors which we cannot modify
for example different material the
primer and the biology let's say that we
have a sandy soil versus a clay soil
those soils are inherently differently
and we cannot modify that see first
but the internet properties interact
with the land use that we give to the
soil
there it's not the same if we're talking
about a forest area or an urban area
in terms of the most important
management practices that we do but also
in terms of the functions that we want
from the soil they are completely
different
and finally we have the management the
management is what we can change at the
former level to really affect or change
the hall so
and these all of these interacting are
the ones that are defining our soil
Health values and where we want to give
a meaning to the values we measure we
need to have reference that are adapted
to these different conditions
so with all this in mind
um my main research goal was try to
disentangle a little bit so-called
drivers and the effect of soil Health in
crop productivity
and I wanted to do this generating
information that can be used to optimize
ergonomic management practice
my research took place in two locations
you know why my home country here in
South America and New York State
and these countries are in very
different Stations of the soil Health
movement Uruguay has a very long history
of trying to preserve soil Health soils
in general reducing soil erosion but we
still don't have any Storehouse lab in
the country and farmers are making the
decision mostly based on soil chemical
properties
in the other hand New York has the first
so-health lab in the in the world
installed and there have been a lot of
progress promoting and studying Soho
yet the challenges are similar in that
we still need to learn a lot about the
complexities in soil Health to really
have very efficient management
strategies and practices that we can
promote for farmers
so I'm going to start talking about my
your wife
the main goals here were three I wanted
to First quantify what is the effect of
agricultural land use in these soils in
this uh Compass region Molly sole that
I'm going to talk a little bit more
about them
I wanted to evaluate how agronomic
practices can lessen or reduce soil
degradation and finally I wanted to look
at the association between so health and
crop productivity
first I'm going to start giving a brief
introduction about Year One as Harold
was saying we are tiny you have probably
never heard about you who I or you have
don't know much about it we're three and
a half million people very small
countries but yet we produce food for
over 30 million people and according to
our government concerning a little bit
this number but we have the potential to
produce food for 60 million people by
2015. that number is scary for me but
that's what we're telling people we are
located here in South America in this
brown area that is the pump at Region
pampiana
um and we have all this potential to
produce a lot of food because our soils
were developed to under temporary
grasslands very deep rooting sister
systems of perennial grasses that lead
to the formation to very fertile soils
and these soils are similar to those
that we can find in the midwest U.S in
Ukraine and some parts of China some of
the most productive soil in the world
that we're performed are under these
pastures
so this map over here is showing so to
give a little bit of context of what is
happening in your why between 2001 and
2012 we had a huge expansion of
agricultural in their region here
Brazilian Argentina and we can see in
the increasing yellow and red and red
colors how agricultural systems
dominated by soybean expand narration
replacing our most traditional
production systems of crop and pastures
integrated together
so in the recent years this is a little
bit more stable you're not seeing this
huge expansion but still an increase in
income in commodity prices would
increase the preservation of our natural
grasslands Uruguay is still 51 on their
natural grasslands and natural
grasslands are one of the most
indentured ecosystems in the globe 70 of
them have been already replaced and is
turning into agriculture
so in my research I evaluate so Health
in three long-term experiments that are
located in the same research station uh
sorry a new show here is here in this
area of Uruguay for those that know
about it and it's in some of the most
fertile soils in the country
so my experiments are in the same
research station meaning that they need
to store properties among them are very
similar we have some difference in slope
and a small difference in texture but
overall similar inner soil conditions
and the experiments were designed to
evaluate some of the most promoted
rationality practices in your region one
the integration of annual crops with
perennial grasses
tillage reductions conventional versus
no pill
crop fertilization and cover crops
Incorporation
the first of this experiment evaluate
the effects of fertilization faster
incorporation and the duration of those
pastures
the experiment was installed in 1963 if
one of the oldest all the oldest of
Latin America
and
you can imagine that production systems
from the 63 to Green days have changed a
lot
so the experiment has evolved as well
following the Tendencies of the region
but yet the main characteristics of the
treatments remain the same
but the changes that happen were mostly
associated with an increase in crop
intensity
at the beginning in the 60s we were able
to have only one crop a year and we were
doing that with a lot of English with
the cost of time and improvements in
technology we were able to reduce
tillage and in since 2009 the experiment
is under no deal as most of the pump as
region production systems nowadays
so here I'm trying to buy some of the
results for my expectation in a spider
plot uh we can see the physical
properties and biological properties
that I measure in a very conventional
spider plot where I score all my
indicators from 0 to 100
and in the inner part of the plot we can
observe the most degraded conditions
that in this case are associated to my
continuous cropping system with no
fertilization
following by that we have a continuous
cropping system fertilizer
and we observe that especially for
biological and and water aggregate
stability uh their soil Health was
almost double with respect to the
non-fertilizer treatment so fertilizing
our crops we're putting back some of the
nutrients that we are extracting in the
brain was crucial for maintaining full
health
farther out we can see the treatment
that incorporates 33 of the time with
perennial passers and these passers are
non-graced pastors that I just could and
the recipe reminds me soil
and then further out we have our other
two treatments one is 50 of the time on
their pastures and the other one is 66
of the time in their processors and
among those two we can observe that they
improve respect with the 33 but they
were not very big difference among them
and then further out I have my reference
area my undisturbed priest in grassland
area with even better mental health so
very important effects of cropping
systems and treatments in this
experiment
and here is a summary of the composite
so Health index so showing the average
of all these indicators for you to have
a more clear easy to see reference
so basically here I'm observing that
fertilization and cardinality had a very
important effect in soil Health
especially perenniality associated with
increasing active plant growth in the
systems
my second experiment evaluates two
factors no till and fostering
Corporation so this one is younger only
26 years and the slope is less than one
percent versus in the previous one was
between two and three so erosion was a
bigger risk in the previous experiment
with compared to this one
again the same kind of a spider plot and
here we can see that they're not very
important difference among treatments so
neither No Deal or Plastering
Corporation generate significant effects
in SoHo but yet the reference always
show a very contrasting difference with
regards to the farming areas
so here no Theo didn't improve soil
health and this is probably associated
with the lower ocean risk of these very
low slope
fight and perenniality didn't improve so
health either and the main difference
between this experiment and the previous
one is this active plant growth period
of the continuous cropping system in
this experiment that is more recent we
started with cropping systems that are
very intense and here is the rotation
it's kind of a small but basically we
have a lot of double crops and a lot of
Sergeant and foreign rotation so very
intense plant growth in continuous
progresses
and then my final experiment evaluates
the effect of cover crop incorporation
sorry
in a continuous soybean system so this
is even younger 15 years old only and we
are seen here in the spider plot the
Inner Line is a continuous soybean
system with nothing growing during the
winter and this is a picture of how
winter it looks like so very dramatic
effect
and the treatments that we evaluate is
incorporating an oat during winter as a
cover crop and terminating that oat
either early two months before planting
the soybeans or one month and we observe
that for the most dynamic soil health
indicators
cover crops had a significant positive
benefit for Soho
so
after finishing this study and and
seeing these very different results for
experiments that were installed in the
same research extension is a stationary
uh especially associated with the
effects of plastering cooperation very
positive in one place and very with no
effects in the other one we start really
thinking about how can we actually
integrate the way we analyze long-term
experiments in a way that we can get
like more con consistent results and I
was reading a lot of meta-analysis
trying to evaluate uh conservation
management effects into in soil health
and they're always saying that the
effects of dealers are inconsistent the
effects of Curry crops are inconsistent
so really start thinking about how can
we very integrate these experiments
so we start thinking about evaluating
sawhall through the lens of our critical
Zone approach so this means that we are
going to be evaluating management
practices through the changes they
generate in the inputs and outputs of
carbon and nutrients to the soil
and using above ground biomass as an
intermediate indicator of those fluxes
and cycles of carbon
so what we did was to in this plot I'm
showing all my experiments together
and for each experiment we selected a
reference treatment that was the worst
conservation strategies had the lowest
biomass return and then we analyzed the
changes that the improved treatment
generate in biomass and Associate that
with the changes we observed in soil
Hall so here are my three experiments
I'm not including the non-fertilizer
treatment because that will make more
noise
but basically what we are seeing is that
changes in biomass explain about 50
percent of the variability in soil
Health which is a very high number and
we also said that neither tillage or the
incorporation of perennials generate
variations in the suffocation
so
so the good thing about looking
experiments like this is that one we are
considering the Baseline condition and
the difference between experiments in
the Baseline condition and also this
allowed us to eliminate the effects of
time and different duration of our
experiments
but most important like knowing this
association between biomass and soil
health will allow will allow us to start
thinking about how can we redesign our
production systems in order to have more
sustainable management practices and
therefore we start thinking about what
are the opportunities to increase
violence
in assistance for your why contacts but
also can be applied for other places
so the first thing you can do if you
want to improve increase your biomass
might be reducing your El gaps and this
is the El Gap map for corn and we can
see that in your why we have an El gap
between two and three tons for corn
the second thing you can do is what we
were evaluating before is try to
incorporate either a winter crop or a
cover crop so you increase and have more
biomass
you can also think about replacing
soybean for a for a crop that it has
higher biomass production like pork and
finally
you can also think about incorporating
perennial grasslands but of course
these changes are also challenging for
farmers and incorporation of perennial
grasslands will bring more complexities
like the need of bringing animals back
to our system
so using the relationships that we
generated and we observe from our
experiment we were able to make and play
with some scenarios so these are the
expected changes after 12 years in by
above ground biomass and therefore in
SoHo so we started from a continuous
soybean system and and first scenario
was what happened if we just reduce
yellow caps and we observed that only
reducing El gaps will not have very
significant changes in biomass and
therefore neither in soil Health but the
incorporation of cover crops or
similarly winter crops can have very
significant improvements in our soil in
our returns of biomasses to the soil and
so how but most interesting is like the
huge variability that we can observe in
this plot and that variability is
associated to having productive power
crops or not and this for the yes
scenario of Uruguay it's important
because a lot of farmers are doing cover
crops but they are not putting the
inputs they need in order to have
productive cover crops and therefore
they might not be having the expected
benefits in soil health and then my
other two scenarios were changing half
of the soybeans for corn and then after
that changing half of the time for
perennial postures and we can see
different results but I think the main
takeaway messages that we are taking
from this exercise is one the changes
and in biomass that we need to see
changes in SoHo take time and we need
time to construct them and this is
12-year scenarios
but also the changes overlap and we
really need to start thinking about what
are the benefits that we get under
different scenarios but of course these
open more questions than the one that we
were able to answer and we're only
focusing focusing on a set of of soil
indicators but things are much more
complex and perennial grassland will
have so many other benefits to the
system that we are not looking in this
exercise right
and now I'm going to talk about my third
um chapter for your wife
here I wanted to see the associations
between soil health and crop yields
and we are looking at soil Health
through the changes in soil organic
carbon in surface
and the interesting thing very unique
thing here in this study is that the
changes in soil organic carbon were
generated by management we have a lot of
studies trying to assess how solorganic
carbon affects crop yields but many
times most of the times the soil samples
are taken for different places so the
changes we are seeing are not
necessarily associated with management
but here
one very cool thing about the first
long-term experiment that I presented
today is that since they started they
have been taking a soil sampling sample
every year and analyzing soil carbon and
that means that I have a data of carbon
for every year together with the data of
fields and the treatments here
continuous passer system huge depletion
in soil organic carbon and then the
different postures in the corporations
that maintain or either sometimes
increase a little bit carbon but
basically the treatments over time have
been generating a lot of variability
into a carbon that now I can see how
it's affecting eels
so what we did was trying to understand
the drivers of Wheaton Valley eels for
this situation and I use corrected eels
because I wanted to eliminate the
effects of the progress in technology
and Improvement in management that
happened during time
and I analyzed that together with 14
explanatory variables
associated with soil climate management
and I did this using a random force
model to see the non-linear
relationships yeah
our models were able to explain 64 of
the variability in deals which is kind
of high for for eel and this plot over
here is showing the variable importance
for the random Forest the only thing you
need to look is the order of the
variables here and I was very impressed
to see that soil organic carbon was the
most important variable in the
definition of yields in these crops that
are non-irrigated and unfertilizer
and this is because soil organic carbon
was reflecting the changes in many
physical and biological properties and
we can see this here how the increase in
solar organic carbon is associated for
example with a decrease in both density
and an increase in aggregate stability
among others
we were also able to see some partial
dependence plot to better understand how
carbon is affecting eons the first thing
I want to highlight here is a huge
variability of carbon that we had in
experiment from 1.2 to 2.4 in a molecule
that change is huge and also we were
able to observe that even above two
percent of carbon we are seeing benefits
of increasing SOC where many people is
saying that two percent is a critical
level of soil organic carbon we are not
seeing here those results
and finally
we were also able to see some of the
interactions of carbon with for example
climatic variables and here I'm showing
solar organic carbon and photothermical
coefficient that is a relationship
between radiation and temperature the
only thing you need to know is that the
higher this value the better climatic
conditions for crop growth so
and in colors are is the crop yield so
what we are seeing here is that if your
soil is degraded
and you have bad chromatic conditions
you're going to have very low yields
but even
if the climatic conditions are good
you're not going to get good yo values
if your soul have been depleted
but when your soil quality improves so
Health improves is when you are gonna be
seeing the benefits of the good climatic
condition so at least in a context of
higher climate variability and climate
change it's very important to have this
information for us to really talk to
Farmers about how important is to
conserve sofas
so the main takeaway messages from my
working Uruguay is that annual
throughout the grade Soho
that regenerative practices can lessen
that degradation but in order to really
understand the effect of a generative
practice we need to start thinking about
the effects the practice have in carbon
and nutrient cycling into the soil and
finally we also find that soil Health in
radiation is associated with real
depletions
and with that we're going to start
talking about New York
okay something happened here
okay okay sorry about that overlap of
things but
New York in contrast to your white has a
very large history of working in soil
health
and the here I try to put all the logos
but I don't know what happened so
basically there's a lot of people
working in soil Health in the state of
New York and all that work that started
at coneo end up leading in the
approvement of a soil health and primary
resiliency act in 2021
which is a very uh Innovative
legislation that New Yorkers should be
very proud about because it's the first
legislation talking about the importance
of preserving soils for farmers
and but yes of course this is also
putting a lot of pressure for us
researchers to really try to understand
better what are these starting
conditions that we have in soil Health
in this state what we can do to
Improvement and how can we do that
efficiently
so one interesting thing about New York
is that it's a very diverse State we
have various pastors vegetables and
animal grains all within the state and
some of the research that Joseph and
Harold have been doing is showing that
soil health is very different between
these different systems here I'm showing
the example for aggregate stability
and what they have been finding is that
those systems that are under under
pastures have higher soil Health values
than those that are under animal
agreeing systems
so basically this is similar to what I
found in Uruguay seeing that the systems
that have high biomass production and
cycling into the soils have better soil
health status than the ones that have
lowers reflection and
so one of the challenges here is to try
to understand the complexities between
the temporal and cross-scale variability
of soil Health within New York State
knowing and repeating the slide about
the interaction between engineering
factors land use and management
so what I wanted to do here is to get
advantage of this amazing data set that
Cornell has been generating with facial
location of each point of protocol and
try to see how these factors are acting
and if we can use remote sense data to
really understand what happens
so my main goals were to analyze the
importance and nature of the
relationship between primer and solved
properties and land use generate maps to
predict so health and evaluate land use
Alternatives and manage potential
changes into a health Associated
management
for this I use all the samples submitted
to the lab between 2014 and 2021 and
this is a non-deliverative example
meaning that the farmers will do
something to us we didn't actively
choose the sample so therefore the word
some unbalanced data so I first I'm I
need to filter a little bit the data set
and focus only in those cases that I
have well like sufficient number of
samples to to have 12 represented
situations therefore I'm gonna be only
analyzing data that was located in
alphysos and dissolves an Inception I'm
not considering Force areas or urban
areas but
today for for only for today
presentation I'm gonna be focusing only
in this blue and purple regions that are
the Finger Lake creation that we are
here right now and then the uh alegany
Plateau mission
my work was a very conventional digital
soil mapping approach that I'm not gonna
go into details but we started with 1
400 samples and after our cleaning we
had between 820 and 920 samples buying a
little bit among indicators
and we use extra model to model so
health and then generated map at 100
meter resolution
and finally we evaluate what we can do
with the maps
the variables that we're trying to
predict are biological
solar organic matter proxy respiration
and protein and physical available water
capacity and wet agreement
and we are also trying to predict and
the composite soil Health index of the
average value of this core values of
individual properties
and this is very I think interesting
because there's a lot of people doing
digital Soul mapping but there are not
many efforts to really map Dynamics
and even though a lot of work has been
done in mapping carbon it's not always
treated as a dynamic property and I'm
gonna be talking a little bit more about
it
the covariates we put in the model were
the traditional climatic solar
topography variables
and I'm gonna talk a little bit about
more about the plant use management
so as I told you we're trying to to
model Dynamic solved properties so for
us was very important to try to
represent land use and biomass and all
these things that we have been thinking
about
so
we use the cropland data layer for the
USDA and look at six years before
sampling so one of the things that
Digital Phone mapping usually does is
integrates samples that we're taking a
different moments
the most traditional approach integrate
samples that were taken in the early 60s
with current samples without considering
whether some the data that samples were
taken but here we're taking a different
approach we're thinking date that sample
was taken and looking at the previous
management only six years
and we are doing that by looking at
three variables one is the cropping
system we use these data layers that it
will tell us what crop was grown in each
30 minute pixel to classify the systems
into cropping system crop faster system
mixed vegetable or continuous pasture
and we also look at the frequency of the
different props and pastures frequency
of fashion travels animal crops and
postures and within the anode crops we
also look at soybean corn and so on and
finally we had um we considered we
wanted to estimate a little bit
productivity and biomass and we did this
by looking at ndvi values and ndvi will
look at the average for six years free
sampling but also the only one year
pre-samplement knowing that we are
trying to simulate very Dynamic soil
properties we were wondering if looking
at one year was more important than six
that's why
and these are some of the results of my
of my work and here I'm showing the
composite soil Health Index this is the
map that we generate
and these are some of the frequency
variables for the validation data set
very good performance for for the
integrated Composite Index this is the
one that we predict better because it's
already an average of many things so it
makes things a little bit easier but
very high R square 0.72 and this is
allowing us to see some tenancies within
the region as here are the Finger Lakes
and we are serving that around Finger
Lakes we're having lower so Health
values
and now we want to understand why and
there are many things happening together
uh for example that is the area where we
have more money and more Alfie soils but
also we have more annual crops in the
region uh less precipitation more
temperature more pH less field so one of
the limitations here is that we have
many confounding factors in our models
and we need to be aware of that
um management and temperature and clima
go together a lot so when we're trying
to predict so Health it's not that easy
to separate the facts but
um
here I'm showing the performance of my
model for my other indicators I don't
have much time today but basically for
all my indicators we have an R square
higher than 0.5 which is I think is very
good for for what we are trying to do
then and except for available water
capacity that we didn't have a good
performance in predicting this indicator
and this was kind of surprising because
available water capacity is the
indicator that has shown to be less
sensitive to management so we were I was
expecting to be able to predict that one
very well but this is also for me like
telling me that there are some
uncertainties in the coverage I put in
in the model and we know that Polaris
for example is not doing so great in
telling us texture variations so also
things that we need to be aware when
we're trying to give a meaning to the
maps and generate
but more important at the map is that
now we're able to try to figure out what
variables are ruling soil Health within
New York State and this is the sharp
values for those familiarize that with
actually boosting and machine learning
but basically the only thing I want you
to know here is my climatic soil and
land use variables is that the bigger
the bar the higher important that via
importance that variables had in my mind
so basically what we're seeing is that
soil climatic climatic variables had the
higher individual effect in our model
followed by textures variables which we
already know but it's interesting to to
see how the models are performing and
also we were able to see how land use is
affecting
um so Hulk
and furthermore we're able to see some
partial dependence of these are sharp
dependence plots basically a partial
dependence plot uh so we can see how
increasing the percentage of passengers
increase or how while on the other hand
increasing the potential the percentage
of annual crops or vegetables is
decreasing soil Health values
and finally we observed for ndvi values
we observe that increasing mean and DVI
values was associated with positive
effects of smaller Health here are some
more dispersed data and not enough
observations but basically positive
benefits of mdvi in simple
and I'm running out of time but finally
we have an exercise that we were trying
to think what we can do with these maps
and these models that we generated so
here we have kayuga and Seneca regions
and and in the map I'm showing what is
the production system that we have in
each one of those areas currently
according to the classifications that I
made and we observe that it's very
interesting we kind of have a natural
experiment here you can see that Cayuga
already has a lot of integrated crop
faster systems a lot of varying where
Seneca we have a lot of continuous
cropping systems and not a lot of theory
so in an exercise we try to see what
happens if we make Seneca look a little
bit more than kayuga for in terms of
and so our scenario is like changing all
continuous cropping areas to crop
pasture systems
basically we take the mean values of all
the covariates associated to management
for a crowd passer system and apply that
to the crop audience
and with that we were able to see what
are the potentials improvements in soil
Health Associated to this change in
management
here is the map of soil house changes
and here is a table summarizing the
result for my different indicators
overall the main takeaway that we found
here is the mean changes in soil Health
are very small
but we found that there are some areas
that are showing higher responses to
management improvements than other ones
and now we can use these to really try
to understand all the complexities in
the drivers and the interaction between
multiple factors and for example here we
know that this story is not very clear
there is a region with higher responses
and higher changes that is actually
Associated to more clearly soils
so we start learning a lot about these
uh with these scenarios
so with that
um
I I don't think I have time right yeah
yeah okay okay five minutes okay great
so
the take make take away messages here is
like one we were able to generate
prediction models and mods for so for
seven soil health indicators Dynamic
properties that we are finding that is
possible to map and we think that these
Maps can be used to to guide some
conservations strategies in the region
but most important maybe they can guide
you something they can guide new new
studies that we need to develop to
better understand what is happening and
what we are seeing
and another interesting thing is that
this map might help us to very better
connect so Health with ecosystem
Services we know that so soil functions
and ecosystem services do not happen at
foreign level but having these Maps
might allow us to really start thinking
about connecting this and we are also
confirming some
other things that we kind of knew before
that as management has a critical effect
in the whole and that those systems or
those variables that are associated with
higher biomass return and vitals to the
soil are the ones thriving Soho
with that my final thoughts are that I
really think that we can use biomass as
an intermediate indicator to try to
understand why management is having or
not effects in soil Health conservation
we found that remote sensitive data can
be used to represent those variables and
biomass changes
and even though we were able to connect
so Health with crop yields in Uruguay I
I still that we still need to further
keep working on on connecting so how to
solve functions
and with that thank you very much
to all of you
because
yeah
so basically the pastures they are coded
mechanically to simulate the gracing
effect but then 100 of their vcu's are
reminding the Box
so we're not
putting back the deal but also we don't
have decreasing because the animals
itself will return a lot of blood
diamonds so it's artificial mechanical
input yeah
thank you
um
in New York so the the main reason is
that we didn't have enough data so
unfortunately now Debbie is developing a
new research area trying to address
those issues but in the original data
set it wasn't well represented so for me
it was not didn't have enough data to
really understand what might be
happening
um
that's a great point and and I think
that
to answer that I am I'm thinking about
fertilization like my first experiment
is showing that if we don't replace
nutrients full degradation is weak we
cannot avoid solder gradation because
the productivity of the crops is going
to decline in the long term so we really
need to start thinking a little bit more
even to replace some bases that we are
not currently adding but but yeah that's
true
yeah I'm wondering how did you validate
the soil test points um because these
were sort of brought in from all kinds
of different people that are submitting
their soil for sampling how did you sort
of verify that the points were accurate
and I know I know you had sort of
filtered out a lot of the ones in urban
areas
houses and things how did you
from the clean set how did you sort of
verify that they were accurate that you
compare it with what was shown in the
CDL and what they reported sort of their
crop or yeah so I did some comparisons
trying to check that as well and
actually Joseph has been working on
these data set a lot and she already
filtered all of that but basically by
eliminating points that that were in
forests or things as a way for us to try
to confirm that but yeah we didn't we
don't have much rather than that
checking what they report and we were
seeing in
in the machinery
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu